welcome back to CBS mornings our next
guest Billy Porter is known for taking
entertainment to an entirely new level
between his Tony's Grammy and Emmy
Awards and his exceptional sense of
style Porter grabs a spotlight wherever
he goes but it was not always an easy
Road Porter Chronicles his journey to
the person that he is today in his
Memoir unprotected and how he says the
Arts saved him the book is out today on
paper back tomorrow actually we have it
today yes Billy Porter joins us right
now how you doing Billy I'm fantastic
I'm so happy to be here with all of you
the big question was what's Billy going
to wear what's he gonna wear and he
doesn't disappoint head to toe Tom Brown
darling all right so great you are an
incredibly open person at least you have
become that you evolved into that but
it's different though when you're
writing a book if you want to be open
and as transparent as you are in this
one
um what was it like revealing yourself
to the world in this way
um it was the only choice for me that I
had somebody called and said I should
write a book and I thought ah
um but I said if I am going to do one
yeah I'm going to tell the truth the
whole truth and nothing but the truth
yeah
um and yeah so that's what I did why you
title it unprotected because
um
unprotected
has a connotation to it that I think
expands Beyond just me and particularly
in this time that we're in
you know in the world right all of us
are unprotected yeah so but you know by
the things and the people in those
institutions right that we think are
supposed to protect us they're not doing
that and so I think you know it's a way
to sort of just hone in you know exactly
because you were called as [ __ ] you
were called the f word you were called
all about your sexuality and you'd go to
your mom and she would say even Jesus
was crucified you're going to be all
right they crucified Jesus it'll be all
right I came home with a busted lip and
a black eye from being bullied she's
like you'll be fine they crucified Jesus
I know Billy and what message did that
send you as a little boy because you
um never gave up you know what I
understood early
was that I had this gift
I had this voice
this singing voice that came from on
high I knew that yes and I knew that if
I could just lean into whatever
that is and whatever that could bring me
I would be okay my art
transformed me my art saved my life art
is healing and it continues to be that
for me and I in the world but even the
art being healing throughout your career
you're told your voice is too high
you're not going to make it maybe you
should start smoking
that was a voice and speech teacher at
uh Carnegie Mellon
um you know this High raspy voice that
everybody knows now you know that wasn't
you that wasn't the way it was supposed
to be flamboyant
all the two extra I see you took none of
that advice I took none of it I mean
none of it ramped it up a little bit
keep going honey we have that moment
with your mama a second ago and speaking
of rejection for a while she rejected
you yeah I mean you know growing up in
the Pentecostal Church uh you know the
Bible is weaponized very often
to control and
you know my sweet sweet mother is the
personification
of what being a Christian really is and
she used the fact that God gave her a
gay child yes to learn what
unconditional love really looks like
that's what my mom did my mom is my hero
and one of the heavier scenes you write
about you realize that you had a fear of
black men yes really got to me yes
because why and how did you work through
that well first and foremost
um black men
for the majority of my life not anymore
and let me just say that right now that
has changed but I was bullied a lot and
I was also molested by my stepfather
um you know
and like I literally just said
that's changed and I'm so grateful to
have lived long enough black straight
men will stop me in the street with
tears in their eyes and say thank you
thank you thank you for teaching me
keep doing what you're doing brother
thank you for teaching me something that
I didn't a blind spot that I didn't know
I see it all the time and it's so moving
yeah and I'm so grateful to stand at the
intersection of that conversation yeah
yeah Gail and I were talking during the
commercial break about that and how
times have changed do you think we're in
a better place culturally in accepting
each other
I do believe
that for the most part we are
and I think
you know with our unfortunately with our
news Cycles
you know they are all for profit now
so if it bleeds it leads so the only
thing we hear about is the negative
right but what the message I want to get
out is the change has already happened
y'all yes it's already happened and
that's what the that's why the pushback
is so severe right because every time
there is a change that is so powerful
you get the pushback that's just life
y'all that's the circle of it your
careers worked out okay listen I first
saw you in pinky pinky Boo and Kinky
Boots yeah Roth invited me to come and I
was I was thrilled to go Kinky Boots was
a big turning point for me in in terms
of knowing you and then you get the role
on uh pose yes ma'am and Ryan Murphy you
said was on your vision board for
decades over a decade is a it's a big
marketing muck behind post yes he's on
your vision board and you get that part
you were on my vision board too just I
was what just so yeah and what yeah all
my black ladies you Oprah you know what
were we doing you were just on the
vision board because you all represented
what could be what was possible for us
as black people and Ryan was on my
vision board because he's not afraid of
extra yes he's not afraid of flamboyance
he's one of the he would he is one of
the people in the market that would
understand and me and embrace the
totality of me and not try to dampen me
not try to silence me really you like
being extra in the book it talks about
your Golden Globe moment where it said
peacock down the aisle down the red
carpet and that Billy Billy Porter shut
down the red carpet before it even began
you put a lot of thought into what
you're going I do put a lot of thought
into it yeah and it's a business y'all
yeah it's like after I did that
yes after I did the Oscar dress you know
somebody called me from the LA Times the
next day and they were like well what do
you think about the people who say oh
you're you're only doing this for
attention I was like that's my job
that's the point why are you why are you
shaming me for being good at my job I
will not be shamed for being that's
literally what the red carpet is foreign